come si fa un tema che agli studenti
solitamente voi prendete il tema in
classe un po sottogamba
un po perché non c'è bisogno di studiare
come per le altre verifiche è un po
perché diciamocelo il tema in classe vi
fa perdere anche due o tre ore di
lezione perciò molti di voi considerando
il tema in classe come un momento di
relax ma se io vi dicessi che imparare a
scrivere bene il tema di può aiutare a
vivere meglio e più consapevolmente la
vostra vita e già perché lungo o breve
che venga il vostro tema l'importante è
che vi dia soddisfazione
un po come la vita prima di andare
avanti vorrei concentrare la vostra
attenzione su una parola e su una
locuzione vuoto
e tanto per tra pochissimo capirete il
perchè qual è il problema iniziale
quando dovete scrivere un tema
il problema è che spesso dopo aver letto
la traccia l'unica cosa che avete in
mente è il vuoto
del resto la traccia non la potete
decidere voi studenti certo potete
sceglierne una tra una rosa che vi viene
proposta ma la traccia non è vostra a un
po come la vita nel sud in nessuno di
noi può scegliere i genitori e nemmeno
il tempo e nei luoghi della propria
nascita
esattamente come accade per il tema cosa
succede di solito succede che voi
leggete le tracce
chiedete ai vostri compagni quali
sceglierà quale traccia sceglieranno e
poi in base all'indice di gradimento che
percepite all'interno della vostra
classe scegliete la traccia buttate giù
4 pensieri alla rinfusa
sul foglio di brutta cercate di qualche
aiuto da parte di qualche compagno che
vi dia qualche suggerimento in modo da
riempire il foglio per almeno una
facciata e mezza e poi quando avete
raggiunto una lunghezza che giudicate
sufficiente ricopiate in bella e nel
giro di un'oretta avete finito e restate
per tutto il resto del tempo a girarmi i
pollici e aspettare che l'ora finisca in
una parola il tema che descrivete è
vuoto perché vuoto perché lo avete
scritto tanto per perché andava fatto
lo avete fatto al risparmio perché più o
meno inconsciamente pensate che le
vostre energie vi debbano servire per
altre cose
certo ci sono cose molto più importanti
che scrivere un tema però in quel
momento
voi avete davanti quel tema quel tema il
vostro ostacolo e voi siete chiamati ad
affrontarlo non lo potete aggirare non
lo potete evitare certo potete fare un
assenza strategica per saltare il tema
la prima o poi dovrete recuperare un po
come nella vita gli ostacoli nella vita
non ce li scegliamo e li dobbiamo
affrontare in qualche modo ci sono due
modi per affrontare gli ostacoli
il primo è con rassegnazione e quindi
lasciando che gli ostacoli prendano il
sopravvento l'altro modo è affrontandoli
io insegno ai miei studenti che è meglio
affrontare gli ostacoli
casomai se sbaglieranno impareranno dei
loro errori perché fallire è
un'opportunità per crescere
se fate le cose tanto per imparerete a
riempire la vostra vita di vuoto capito
il paradosso riempire di vuoto se invece
volete dare significato alla vostra vita
allora allenatevi anche con il tema ma
allora
come si scrive un buon tema tanto per
cominciare
liberiamoci di due ostacoli due parole
vuoto e tanto per via da questo momento
non ci servono più
un tema è come un pranzo di gala che
prevede tre momenti ben distinti
l'antipasto il momento delle portate
principali primo e secondo e poi il
dessert
allo stesso modo il tema per chiamarsi
tale deve essere composto da tre
elementi l'introduzione lo svolgimento e
la conclusione
ognuna delle tre parti è importante
nessuna e accessoria tutte sono
necessarie questo vuol dire che senza
una di queste parti il tema risulta
incompleto partiamo dall'antipasto
l'introduzione l'introduzione deve
contenere un assaggio qualche
anticipazione di ciò che verrà poi
esposto nella ma in maniera più estesa
durante lo svolgimento
e chiaro che se le portate principali
sono di pesce
l'introduzione l'antipasto non può
essere di carne per non disorientare per
non sviare la coerenza è importante in
cucina ma noi anche quando si scrive un
tema altra cosa importante
l'introduzione non deve essere troppo
pesante e nemmeno troppo abbondante
esattamente come l'antipasto per non
stancare ancora prima che il pranzo
incominci deve stuzzicare stuzzicare la
voglia di andare avanti
quindi non esagerate infilateci una
frase ad effetto una battuta qualcosa
che invogli a proseguire il lettore e
vediamo
veniamo alla parte principale lo
svolgimento come per un buon piatto la
mano del cuoco è fondamentale deve
essere riconoscibile da parte di un
commensale però mentre si assapora un
piatto è importante anche riconoscere la
qualità
gli elementi di base degli ingredienti
che devono essere ingredienti di qualità
tradotto per il tema lo svolgimento deve
contenere idee riflessioni originali e
personali che sarebbero la mano del
cuoco e che quindi devono essere vostre
è solo vostre ma che traggano
ispirazione dalle vostre conoscenze gli
ingredienti principali
le conoscenze che avete acquisito nel
tempo a scuola ma anche al di fuori
della scuola che rappresentano gli
ingredienti di qualità
assaggiando un buon piatto è possibile
assaporare il gusto della pietanza ma è
importante riconoscere anche il
contributo dei singoli ingredienti
utilizzati
allo stesso modo il vostro tema deve
essere letto dall'insegnante in modo che
egli possa apprezzare la vostra
elaborazione personale ma anche le
vostre conoscenze che avete acquisito
perché non esistono idee degne di essere
prese in considerazione che non siano
suffragate da solide conoscenze dunque
nello svolgimento
qualsiasi sia la traccia metteteci del
vostro ma fate pure riferimento alle
vostre conoscenze che so una citazione
colta qua e là non ci sta mica male
non si può fare il brodo soltanto con
l'acqua ci vuole anche la carne infine
nessun pranzo è dignitoso senza un buon
dessert
esattamente come nessun tema e completo
senza una degna conclusione nella
conclusione bisogna tirare le somme
avanzare delle proposte e chiudere una
storia infondere una morale in modo che
quello che abbiamo detto quello che
abbiamo esposto acquisisca un senso il
senso di tutte le cose si rivela alla
fine ricordate bene il pranzo può essere
stato anche eccellente ma se il dessert
non soddisfa e non è all'altezza
allora va in malora tutto il pranzo
attenzione dunque a come concludete il
vostro tema ci vuole una riflessione
acuta
ci vuole un pensiero profondo che
racchiude il senso di quello che avete
scritto fino a quel momento ma che
sappia anche suggerire la vostra visione
del mondo
vi ricordate all'inizio quando vi dicevo
che un tema e un po come la vita è un
ciclo se il tema un'introduzione uno
svolgimento e una conclusione la vita
un'infanzia una età adulta e una
vecchiaia un ciclo unico e irripetibile
un'unica infanzia un'unica età adulta
un'unica anzianità un'unica vecchiaia
giuseppe ungaretti scrisse le sue poesie
più intense
durante la grande guerra era partito
come volontario per contribuire a
esaltare la gloria della nazione
italiana era partito per la gloria e una
volta al fronte trovò l'orrore il freddo
il fango la morte è proprio immerso in
questo orrore scrisse delle poesie che
celebravano il senso più profondo della
vita in una di queste poesie sereno del
1918 giuseppe ungaretti racconta di una
nottata passata al fronte nelle trincee
in un momento in cui il cielo da
nuvoloso
piano piano si dirada le nuvole si
diradano e lasciano trasparire le stelle
e alla loro vista
al termine della poesia un greti a con
una rivelazione
mi riconosco immagine passeggera presa
in un giro immortale ha così sia la
conclusione del vostro tema
un'intuizione che colpisca che affascini
che faccia riflettere che vada oltre le
barriere della superficialità che
oggigiorno ci circonda che sappia
gettare lo sguardo oltre i limiti che
dia la misura della profondità del
vostro essere che non sia vuota ne è
buttata lì tanto per che sia piuttosto
piena di significato così come mi auguro
sarà anche tutta la vostra vita
[Musica]